malheureusement ce faux-pas sanitaire
c'est parfois un vrai passe pour la mort
le faut parce qu il est normal de lutter
contre le faux pas près de deux cent
mille faux pas sanitaires et plus de 400
enquêtes ouvertes c'est un nouveau type
de fraude apparu avec l'épidémie de
choléra 19 pour échapper à la
vaccination et accéder au restaurant bar
cinéma alors comment les fraudeurs
procède-t-il pour tromper les autorités
et peut-on mesurer l'ampleur de ce
phénomène réponse dans facture
[Musique]
il ya d'abord ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la petite fraude ici on ne parle pas de
vrais faux pas sanitaire mais d'un pas
salutaire que l'on aurait emprunté à un
ami un proche ou à de la famille pour
continuer à mener une vie normale le qr
code renvoie donc bel et bien à une
injection de vaccin qui a été effectué
les vrais faux pas sanitaire eux sont
créé entièrement de façon frauduleuse et
il y a en gros deux cas de figure soit
le personnel médical est impliqué soit
dans la majorité des cas le personnel
médical a été victime d'un piratage une
fois que vous avez reçu votre dose celui
qui vous a vacciné doit l'enregistrer
sur la plateforme vaccin qu'ovide qui
permet de délivrer un certificat pour ça
rien de plus simple chaque professionnel
de santé disposent d'un identifiant en
numéro rpps disponibles en libre accès
et d'un mot de passe fourni via son
téléphone il suffit que le pirate met la
main sur le mot de passe et le numéro
d'authentification pour générer de faux
parce
la manière la plus facile pour les
hackers de récupérer les identifiants
c'était tout simplement d'aller pirater
les établissements comme l'ordre des
médecins ou l'ordre des pharmaciens où
sont stockés en fait et comme le mot de
passe des professionnels de santé qui
leur permet ensuite de créer des
certificats sur les plates formes comme
bac 5 au vide sinon on a d'autres
techniques comme le phishing ou
hameçonnage qu'on va envoyer un mail un
professionnel de santé
veuillez cliquer sur ce lien rend très
positifs y en est là voilà c'est facile
une fois qu'on les a récupérés il est
rentré soi même sur les plateformes et
on peut créer virtuellement à l'infini
n'est pas sanitaire avec avec ces
techniques sinon on n'a pas besoin
d'aller aussi noirci il suffit de se
connecter sur un ordinateur qui a été
laissé ouvert que le professionnel les
laisser noté sur un bout de papier a
besoin d'aller jusqu'à la cie maire
d'agde il ya d'un côté ceux qu'on
pourrait appeler la criminalité
opportuniste ce sont des individus
lambda sur les réseaux sociaux qui tente
de vendre les faux-pas sanitaire qui me
sont piratés ou même un ou deux au
dossier on assure des masses d'argent
assez importante pour le reste après
c'est pas forcément d'être eos mon
argent 100 euros et puis ça peut monter
jusqu'à 500 voire 600 euros dans
certains dossiers
c'est seulement dans certains cas assez
rare donc que l'on peut parler de
criminalité organisée
comme en décembre 2021 lorsqu'un réseau
a été démantelé pour avoir permis de
créer dix mille faux pas sanitaires pour
plus de 2 millions d'euros écoutons le
général c'est vraiment lyon je suis le
chef de l'office central de lutte contre
les atteintes à l'environnement et la
santé publique le classement n'est sûr
des hackers qui vont réussir à pénétrer
frauduleusement des bases de données une
des sites sur lesquels ils vont
récupérer les noms d'utilisateurs et les
mots de passe des professionnels de
santé là on est sur des cas qui sont
beaucoup plus lisez les mets qui ont
permis de générer un bon nombre de faux
parce les failles qui ont été exploitées
assez rapidement elle ont été identifiés
et puis deux puis asiatiques oblige
les vendeurs comme les utilisateurs de
faux-pas sanitaires sont ainsi traqué
par des unités conjointes de la
gendarmerie de la police avec la
collaboration des ministères de la santé
et de la justice commandement de la
gendarmerie dont six dans l'espace ça
prive initiative d'effectuer sur les
réseaux des cyber-patrouilles pour
identifier des profils qui proposait à
la vente des faux-pas sanitaire par du
temps c'est des flux qui passe des
moyens numériques que ce soit paypal
décrypte aux monnaies des plateformes de
paiement en ligne voire des cagnottes
lille qui sont créées c'est donc soit le
personnel médical qui portent plainte
soit l'assurance maladie qui alertent
les autorités après avoir repéré des
anomalies dans ses systèmes
informatiques
ces gendarmes et policiers qui sont
spécialisés en cybercriminalité et en
criminalité financière traque ainsi sur
les réseaux sociaux et les messageries
crypter les fraudeurs qui pourrait
essayer de vendre et faire de la
publicité pour de faux passe
le problème c'est que depuis le début de
la crise ce sont bien les établissements
de santé qui sont les premières cibles
et les premières victimes de ces cyber
attaques en ce qui concerne la
protection de ses services on est quand
même vraiment vraiment en retard là
dessus il est prévu notamment à l'ump
est sous travaillons pour mettre en
place des formules d'apprentissage de
perfectionnement de sensibilisation
cybercriminels ont véritablement une
longueur d'avancé rapport aux
professionnels de santé et il est assez
difficile en fait en l'espace de peu
près deux ans de pandémie de rattraper
ce retard vous avez une génération de
jeunes praticiens qui use son nez dans
l'informatique le numérique pour le ça
coule de source que vous avez quand même
une génération qui est plus âgée mais
qui n'a pas forcément autant
d'automatismes on a besoin de formation
oui sur la sécurité comment se défendre
et c'est pas simple pour mes activités
professionnelles je dois avoir pas loin
d'une centaine de mots de passe c'est
compliqué
pour les fraudeurs identifiés comme pour
les détenteurs d'un faux parce c'est
donc jusqu'à cinq ans d'emprisonnement
et de 75000 euros damende qu'ils
risquent et le gouvernement continue de
serrer la vis le texte instaurant le
fasse vaccinale et non plus à me taire
prévoit de durcir les sanctions si vous
comptiez présenter un pass qui
appartient à un ami mais que vous fait
coincer ce n'est plus une amende de 135
euros mai 2000 euros qu'il faudra payer
seule façon d'y échapper
si vous êtes un repenti traduction si
vous prenez rendez vous pour une
première dose de vaccin dans les 30
jours suivant l'infraction
le pic de la fraude a surtout été le
mois 2 le mois de juillet sur les 400
dossiers qui sont ouverts aujourd'hui
200 ont été ouverts pendant les tests
35% ou été ouvert en septembre et
octobre et on continue sur la pente
décroissante puisqu'on à 15% des
procédures qui ont été ouvertes au cours
des mois de novembre et décembre il ya
des gros dossiers qui sont en cours qui
devrait logiquement aboutir dans les
semaines à venir donc logiquement on
devrait plus avoir d'apparition de
grosses affaires avec des faux-pas
s'aliter
même si le ministère de l'intérieur a
expliqué au figaro qu'il ne pouvait pas
mesurer précisément si ces chiffres
étaient sous-estimés ou pas c'est
pourtant sûrement le cas car sur tout ce
qui fausse les chiffres se sont tous les
vrais passe sanitaire que certains
empruntent à un proche pour éviter de se
faire vacciner et comme les gérants des
bars des cinémas ou encore des
restaurants ne sont pas autorisés à
contrôler l'identité beaucoup passe
sûrement sous le radar des autorités ce
qui peut se refléter dans certains
hôpitaux selon une enquête de nos
confrères de france info selon carol lee
chez chef du service de réanimation au
chu de nice 30% de ces malades en soins
intensifs son détenteur d'un faux parce
sanitaires et avec le remplacement du
pass sanitaires par le passé vaccinale
il est certain que les autorités restent
sur le qui-vive face à une potentielle
intensification des trafics